okay we were just talking about mass you
said at Honeywell the president was told
by the folks at Honeywell Ellis was the
team that they didn't need to wear masks
because the people who would be
interacting with him had all been tested
and had been shown to be negative before
that took place I guess so the president
had the circumstances obviously he's the
president so why shouldn't all Americans
who go back to work be able to get a
test before they do to feel comfortable
in their own work environment to be
interacting with other individuals you
know let's dismiss a myth about tests
right now a notion that everyone needs
to be tested is just simply nonsensical
the people who need to be tested are
vulnerable populations
that's why dr. Burks has repeatedly
emphasized we need to search nursing
homes with the testing meat processing
facilities that's where the testing is
needed we have to be strategic with our
testing and we have done that so we
tested every single American one per
capita are higher than other countries
we have two times we've conducted two
times another the number of tests of
other countries around the world we're
at a very strong place in this country
of testing but rest assured we'll deploy
it strategically because that's what the
American public expects of us to be
clear should people I guess should
people accept the risk that they could
become ill if they go back to work well
each and every state has put into place
this is a governor led effort first of
all let me emphasize that the president
has said that governor's make the
decisions as to how to move forward and
we encourage them to follow our phased
approach each state has submitted to us
a list of testing that they need in
order to safely reopen I was sitting in
the meeting when Admiral Zhao pulled out
the list for several states and said
here's the testing you were requested to
open safely here's the testing I'm
giving you to meet that need it's pretty
extraordinary this wide scale effort by
the Trump administration to ensure
states have what they need so as States
reopen they'll do so safely and they'll
do so with the supplies of the trumpet
and I always are following the
guidelines that the president dictated
from this podium we encourage every
single governor to follow the guidelines
that we've put forward to a phased
reopening approach we have this
beautiful concept called federalism
which means that the states lead on this
and that's what that's what we're doing
it's governor led decision but we
encourage everyone to follow the expert
in urban areas what is the White House
of doing or is there any targeted effort
to help stop the spread in the morning'
communities yeah it's a very important
question because we know that some of
our underserved communities are hit most
by the coronavirus absolutely we've done
quite a bit that was was geared towards
specifically ensuring and men and women
in underserved communities and those
hospitals got that money and I would
also know just that the president has
directed secretary ben Carson to focus
the White House opportunity and
revitalization Council on underserved
communities so very important this is a
community that's been very hard hit and
rest assured we are laser focused on
making sure that these communities are
assisted ok so the task force has put
out faiths guidelines for states to
reopen an individual guidelines but it
hasn't said very much about businesses
specifically does it plan to put out any
detailed guidelines for businesses like
retailers and restaurants to reopen well
on the phased approach there are some
recommendations for how for instance
restaurants should reopen on the
distancing that's required and as you go
through the phases that distancing is
shrunk and there are other mechanisms
that are outlined for restaurants and
movie theaters and sporting venues so I
would argue that our phased approach
does take that into account in each and
every state by the way the governor is
welcome to reach out to us we're
constantly communicating with the
governors and when I say we the
administrator
meaning dr. Burks and others so we are
happy to consult with her with regard to
specific detailed some other organism
outside organizations how quick you know
very detailed step-by-step here's what
you should do should require mass you
should require them to sit this far
apart you should only have half of it
each and every state by the way the
governor is welcome to reach out we're
constantly community well government
will consult and we do so each and every
day so you usually praise warriors as
part of everyday Americans and
presidents using that phrase as well
what's the thinking behind using that
description and is that basically asking
the American to put themselves in harm's
way in harm's way like warriors do not
in the slightest it's actually the
opposite you know the president's been
clear that at this moment you know we're
at a wartime moment where we're fighting
the invisible enemy and by that I mean
kovat 19 and on the contrary the the
notion that the American people are
warriors they're warriors because
they've stayed home they're warriors
because they've social distance they're
warriors because this mitigation effort
is something that could only be done by
the American people coming together and
making really hard sacrifices and the
American public has done that and we
salute each of you around the country
that have listened to these guidelines I
know it's been difficult I know it's
been hard but it's because of you that
we're at this place where we can reopen
the country clear that's the opposite
what the president says specifically
because he says Americans must be
warriors to reopen the economy but
people call me we're saying me we're
saying the exact same thing the
president says they're warriors to
reopen because guess what in order to
get to reopening you have to social
distance um you had to put it together
those very hard choices that allowed us
to get to a point where we have the one
of the lowest mortality rates in the
world and that's because of the American
people so it took the American people
being warriors if you're saying Oh
me word same exact same thing that next
week ten days or so as to whether or not
they're living up to the deal China is
as it stands though right now at this
moment how does the White House view the
u.s. relationship with China right now
right now it's a relationship of
disappointment and frustration because
the president has said how frustrated he
is that some of the decisions of China
put American lives at risk I'll share
just a few that China for instance did
not share the genetic sequence until
after a professor in Shanghai did so on
his own and after that genetic sequence
was shared the next day the lab was shut
down for quote rectification the World
Health Organisation's slow-walked
information on human to human
transmission that was not adequately
provided by China China didn't let us
investigators in and look that those
decisions put American lives at risk and
the president is certainly not happy
about that and as president said you'll
be hearing more about that next is
forward sorry may be trusted business
partners the president has worked with
China and stood up to China and got the
Phase one China deal was not heard fifty
billion dollars the president managed to
get that done and the president
appreciates that that China got us to
that point of the phase one China deal
so you know I'll give it to the
president as to how we move forward and
I certainly won't get ahead of him on
that that's practices we heard the
president say as it relates to schools
that he wants to see schools open but
maybe teachers who are old older than 60
not necessarily come back you see
billion dollars president man attacked
with a family member who might be older
than 60 per se what is the White House
advice upon that and families who are
all over the country saying is it time
to meet up again well the president
attached force have been clear that
vulnerable Americans are senior citizens
need to shelter him
when you talk about real being the
economy reopening the country getting a
lot of people out there wondering well
my slow age child
Jamaica back in pecan where as mentioned
that influx of asymptomatic coronavirus
cases without more widespread testing
how do you get a handle on something
like that and how do you keep people put
outside them from spreading the disease
around the country yeah so it's an
important question we get information on
asymptomatic spread when we test in the
meat processing facilities and other
facilities again you know we can just
test strategically and it's important
that once we test and we find on an
example of someone who has corona virus
that we can contact trace and ensure
that it's not spread to other members of
the community so contact tracing is an
important measure and we're testing
strategically and in line with
governor's John what's the process candy
for the distribution and access to rent
disappear yeah Ramdev severe is a great
example of innovation in this country I
would note that I'm disappear is a drug
that the president mentioned quite often
and as it turns out there's a lot of
hope and a lot of promise when it comes
to him to severe on Gilead chairman
announced announced that they would be
donating 1.5 million vials of herim
dessa vir and working with the federal
government to distribute to patients
across the nation so this will get out
there and we think Gilley ad for the
great work they've done on and for
giving these 1.5 million vials which
will help a lot of Americans around the
country but what's the process for
distributing it and giving access to
patients I speak I'm CEO Daniel O'Day
and now it would be donating 1.5 million
the house because it's filled with Trump
how is that consistent with oversight
and transparency well first of all um
but the president noted was specific to
the house it's important to note that
dr. felt you will be testifying before
the Senate which means he will be
feeling questions from both Democrats
and Republicans the house however and
specifically chairwoman Nita Lowey skom
it II did not act in good faith
mark Meadows had three calls with
chairwoman Nita Lowey
three nights ago when she called task
doctor felt she could testify before a
subcommittee hearing and chief of staff
mark meadows has made clear he wants to
make the best use he can of the task
force members time of course they're
working hard to save American lives so
that's very important so to that end he
said in the three phone calls you know
what is the purpose of this hearing can
you give me the subject matter and LOI
was unable to tell the chief of staff
what the subject matter was the last
phone call they had was at 10:40 6:00
p.m. on that evening and LOI agreed to
follow up in the morning with das first
ever received instead we got a press
release so that's what we call a
publicity stunt we encourage the house
to act in good faith but much like the
Senate did and as I noted dr. Fauci will
be speaking in a week and a half before
the Senate so the notion that he's being
blocked is just farcical received
instead we got a press release so office
on the mortality rate I would note as I
noted just a few moments ago we have one
of the lowest in the world mortality
rates it's because of the hard work of
the American people armor our mortality
rate excuse me is currently 218 per
million
um you compare that to Spain's at 548
per million Italy at all
the truce always oh no just a few
moments ago office or put in place by
the American people
yes the president has said many times
that he's received praise in phone calls
with foreign leaders because of this
administration's response to the corona
virus outbreak who exactly are those
heads of states and heads of governments
who are praising this administration for
its responsible well I won't some reveal
any contents of his private
conversations with world leaders but I
will certainly share some of the very
public comments from Democrat governors
like Gavin Newsom who said every single
direct request that President Trump that
he was given a president Trump was
capable of meeting he has met them
Governor Phil Murphy Democrat from New
Jersey the president knows New Jersey he
and his team have been extremely
responsive in our hour of need whether
it was ventilators we got a huge amount
of supplies to test and of course I love
the ones from Governor Andrew Cuomo who
praised this administration's for a
response is phenomenal saying he's
delivered for New York the Army Corps of
Engineers we built thousands of beds he
sent the Navy ship comfort to New York
he has delivered for New York President
Trump has delivered for this nation
thank you the president was talking
earlier about dr. bright being a
disgruntled employee one of the
allegations in that whistleblower
complaint is that in January when there
was still a huge shortage of n95 masks
in New York he has delivered for New
York President Trump has delivered which
then subsequently exported 1 million and
my device to China
is that something that you're looking
into or concerned about okay I'm on
issues of dr. bright I'd refer you to
HHS I'm not going to get involved with
the personnel issues or the substance of
that complaint but I will once again I
know you mentioned masks 70 million plus
delivered and again that's three times
the amount used by health care providers
in any given year so we've done a rather
good job when it comes to supplies
that's the question about teachers and
what the president said earlier about
keeping those who are 60 or older out of
the classroom what is the message to
older Americans should they not do
anything not meet their homes until
there is a vaccine or what would the
president have been doing if they are
they're not allowed to teach because
their age well our task force has said
that vulnerable communities like our
seniors should shelter in place that
being said we encourage every American
if you have a symptom that is pressing
that you need to go to your
many quotes from doctors I'm stories of
people who are staying home with chest
pain and and don't go to the hospital
when they could be on the verge of
having a heart attack who are missing
important appointments like mammograms
screenings like colonoscopies it's
important that we as Americans continue
to go to our doctors to get medically
necessary after I've been started to
read many hoods from doctors stories
people or say or provided go to the
hospital should you have a symptom like
that going back to you a topic about the
house in a separate chamber acting DNI
Rick Grinnell has stated this week that
he's prepared to release about 6,000
pages with procedures and we have
symptoms that need to be addressed and
that you do owe your doctor so seniors
need to go to their doctors on nature
and all your health care provider goes I
don't have any information on that
subject matter that's um the first time
hearing of that too much' Jeff's
question about doctor pouchy and in the
president's statement that they're too
many Trump haters in the house I mean it
does the White House really believe that
you can decide to have officials
testifying the republican-controlled
Senate but not testifying the Democratic
controlled house doesn't the house have
legitimate oversight and a legitimate
employer responsibility not just not
just the you know authority but
responsibility to have somebody like
Anthony Fauci testify well dr. Fauci be
questioned by Democrats in that Senate
hearing yes what are you saying that so
the Senate's fine the house has no role
in oversight the house needs act in good
faith we don't have time in the middle
of a pandemic for publicity stunts it's
not the time for that it's not the place
for that and the course of trust in the
course of three phone calls you should
be able to give the subject matter to
ensure it's the best use of dr. fauci's
time as you yourself noted and the
republican-controlled Senate dr. Fauci
will indeed be asked questions by demo
the subject matter of mr. Gailey in a
previous life before you were press
secretary you work for the campaign and
you made a comment I believe on Fox in
which you said president Trump will not
allow the coronavirus to come to this
country given yourself noted and their
public in controlled Senate doctor fell
to and it was the intent behind those
travel restrictions which is we will not
see the coronavirus come here
we will not see terrorism come here
referring to an earlier set of travel
restrictions I guess I would turn the
question back on the media and ask
similar questions does Vox want to take
back that they proclaim that the
coronavirus would not be a deadly
pandemic does the Washington Post want
to take back that they told Americans to
get a grip the flu is bigger than the
coronavirus does the Washington Post
likewise want to take back that our
brains are causing us to exaggerate the
threats of the coronavirus does the New
York Times want to take back that fear
of the virus may be expressed
spreading faster than the virus itself
does NPR want to take back that the flu
was a much bigger threat than the corona
virus and finally once again the
Washington Post would they like to take
back but the government should not
respond aggressively to the corona virus
I'll leave you with those questions so
maybe you'll have some answers in a few
days
sector it was a much bigger